hello I'm C I'm happy to present our
work generalized private inspection and
testing with high confidence which is a
joint work with Elise jelan tamash and
URI
so this paper is a paper about
differential privacy let's start by
giving a quick review of the definition
so differential privacy is a
mathematical framework for protecting
individual privacy in computation so for
my speaking takes two parameters
epsilona Delta and randomize the
algorithm a is called Epsilon comma
Delta differentially private a for any
two adjusting the data sets d and e
Prime that differ on only one item X and
a set e it holds that the probability
that aod lies in the cell e is
multiplicatively close to the
probability that aov Prime is in a set e
up to an additive failure probability of
Delta so internally it tells you that
whether X parties face in accommodation
or not has little impact on the result
and in this way the privacy of the
individual X is protected
so generally speaking smaller Epsilon
and Delta are better for privacy and
roughly speaking we can interpret this
definition essay with the probability
one minus Delta the algorithm is
absolute private
now here is the outline for the rest of
the talk uh we will first state the
background the problems we are
interested in solving and our results
our progress towards solving the
problems so this part is further
splitting into two subsections Private
Selection and private testing in the
second part of our talk we would like to
mention a technical highlight of our
paper which is a method for boosting
confidence for privacy testing and spice
Vector technique and then I will
conclude the talk
let's move on into the first part of our
paper the Private Selection
here the background is that we are
interested in solving a task Pi with our
primary data ID in a private Manner and
for this task let's say we have okay
different candidate algorithms is
someone up to a sub k each of them
satisfies privacy absolute zero DP
however for our private data D we don't
know which one is the best one for
solving the task on this on our data and
we want to find out and use the best one
to achieve the best possible utility the
most naive attempt would be running each
algorithm once and then finding an
output in the best one
however if you analyze the privacy of
this total algorithm you can think of it
as a composition of K independent
running
Epsilon comma 0dp algorithms the Privacy
bonus simply degrades to K Epsilon comma
0dp or Epsilon Times Square Root key
comma Delta DP if you use the so-called
Advanced composition theorem so this is
a very pessimistic analysis uh it allows
you to publish all of your key outcomes
when for running the key algorithms but
however in our scenario we are
interested in only in the best algorithm
and the best outcome can we do better
uh before studying our results let me
mention two prior Works uh first in
stock 2019 Leo and Tower showed a
remarkable result which is the first
Private Selection algorithm that selects
from an uptrend number of private
candidates the Sim collection algorithm
has a reasonably good utility guarantee
it satisfies three Epsilon comma zero DP
so the Privacy degradation is a factor
of three which is independent of the
number of candidates uh we also
considered improving the constant 3
further and come up with two plus little
one overhead version of their algorithm
but the analysis and the algorithm get
much more advanced and we can only
achieve approximately P meaning DP bound
with a strictly positive Delta
uh
here the main idea of their algorithm is
to run each candidate for random number
of times and then select the best
outcome so by randomizing the number of
executions of each base algorithm the
Privacy is somewhat uh protected
magically
uh the beautiful subsequent work by
paper note and stank presented yet
another selection algorithm satisfying
two plus before one Epsilon comma 0dp
for any desired Alpha
so uh yeah we can achieve this two plus
little one Epsilon DP guarantee with a
substantially simpler algorithm and they
also put forward a framework for
analyzing private installation under the
Gen edpu framework
which is very nice
uh now we are ready to introduce our
results so we can in this paper we come
up with a general framework for doing
Private Selection and testing will apply
our framework to the Private Selection
part we get a private algorithm that
selects from Key private candidates and
satisfies two plus little one Epsilon
comma 0dp and compared with the low
Tower algorithm our algorithm has the
same Advantage as the paper Notch tank
algorithm namely it is faster and it
always achieves pure DP as long as we
started from Pure DP based algorithms
and comparing with the paper knot slang
algorithm our algorithm achieves the
same constant factor meaning that the
two plus little one however algorithm
has a additional advantage of being
easier to prove so in particular our
analysis doesn't need to go through the
granny DP calculation
and I would also like to mention that it
is proved by Leon tower that uh overload
our two in the Privacy degradation is
optimal if you want to select from many
DP candidates so in that sense the
little Tower algorithm or pepperonaut
stanker algorithm and our algorithm are
essentially optimal in terms of the
Privacy overhead
uh as our second set is our results we
observe that we can use the Private
Selection framework to boost the
confidence part for many uh the basic
data analysis tasks so this is kind of a
simple observation but in our opinion
it's very useful because the original
motivation for doing Private Selection
is to do hyper parameter tuning in
private machine learning and you have to
observe that this Private Selection
framework is powerful enough so that for
many basic data analysis tasks we can
use it to improve the confidence Bound
for giving algorithms easily maybe a
representative example is the problem of
releasing counting queries
so let's see the application now uh uh
let's describe the problem first here we
are giving a set as a population and we
want to privately answer the accounting
queries for example the set s can be all
the people leaving a particular area and
we are interested in a bunch of
accounting queries each query is
available for our name many people in
your set satisfies the statement p
okay so this is the counting query and
understanding the utility privacy
trade-off for this problem is kind of a
fundamental question of DP and has been
studied extensively over the past decade
so here by this trade-off I mean we fix
a privacy bound Epsilon and Delta and we
want to ask what's the best accuracy we
can achieve in answering these queries
and in terms of approximately DP we're
following two results are somewhat the
state of the art results so the first
one is by gazi Kumar and monogram C
which shows that for any Epsilon Delta
we came up with the algorithm
satisfying Epsilon comma Delta DP such
that with high probability answers all
over the C questions accurately here
quantitatively by accurate I mean their
algorithm outputs a quantity that is
additively close to the ground choose by
an additive error or at most while we're
at Epsilon Times Square Root C Times log
1 over Delta this additive error term is
known to be optimal namely there is a
matching lower balance
a concurrent work by Daga and core shows
that for any Epsilon Delta such that as
long as there is a mild restriction on
the Delta parameter they can come up
with the Epsilon comma Delta DP
algorithm such that with probability one
answers all the sequence accurately
so having a problem with probability one
guarantee is desired in some cases and
the KML result as itself cannot achieve
this on the other hand the gkm algorithm
works for the four parameter regime of
Delta whereas the Diagon core algorithm
only products with lower bound and Delta
and here we observe that if we use the
Private Selection framework on top of
the gtml reason we can kind of achieve
best over those words namely for any
Epsilon Delta parameter we are
interested we can answer all the
questions accurately with probability
one
so
um that's our results for query
releasing and that's all I want to say
about Private Selection let's move on to
the priority testing part
here we have even more interesting
background let's say suppose you have a
claim P about your private data ID for
example the claim can be that the
majority of the individuals in the data
set satisfies a given claim uh now you
would like to design a private test to
verify the truthful on this p and
also you want to only pay the Privacy
loss only if PA is not satisfied
uh this requirement is kind of intuitive
and natural because if the claim is
indeed satisfied it would not be a
surprise to you you because you come up
with the claim you don't need learn
anything new from this verification
uh and only P being force is kind of
very surprising to you and tells you
substantially something new about the
data set
uh so they are in literature there is a
classical example of this abstract task
namely the sparse Vector technique which
can be used to verify claims of the form
and for the data set is less than a
threshold for one lip change function f
here being one bit she is I just mean
that if we add change at any single
entry in my data set the F value of the
data set changes by at most y okay so
the first Vector tank can be used to
take verify claims of the form and we
pay the Privacy loss only if the outcome
is about the threshold if the outcome is
below the threshold we pass the query
without apparently paying the Privacy
loss so potentially one can use fast
Vector technique to answer an unbounded
number of queries
so before starting our results let's
also mention the previous work uh in
this field won't work value on the tower
we have already considered generalizing
the sparse Vector technique to handle
arbitrary private verifiers so here to
model an abstract or an arbitrary
product verifier and claim uh let hbi
find the algorithm with binary outcome
which we think of it as a verifier for
the player so its outcome is either
accept or reject
and given such a primary verifier Liu
and Tower design an algorithm to
simulate hrd that size twice two
properties so first the r simulation is
kind of useful meaning that if H over by
that data set outputs accept or reject
with the probability very close what to
Y then it means my data set is extremely
satisfied with the property of extremely
unsatisfied and since the outcome is
kind of determined the simulation is
also output except or reject with high
probability in order for it to be useful
or to be faithful so this is a utility
requirement and in terms of privacy we
would like to have the property that the
simulation only increased our privacy
loss only when the outcome is rejected
as we have said if the outcome is accept
it's not it's kind of not considered a
surprise to the data analyst and we
don't want to pay privacy cost in that
case
uh this is very nice for however there
are some limitations with their
algorithm uh so first of all in general
this simulation does not offer pure DP
even if you start with a short DP uh
verifier Edge so namely the end with a
privacy bound with strictly positive
Delta
and another drawback of the algorithm
might be that the algorithm has a high
running time in order to run their
simulation they need to uh run the
average Runner verify given verifier
Edge for many many times and do some
highly involved post-processing which
makes their proof very complex
complicated
uh we are ready to introduce our results
so when applying our framework to the
private testing scenario we have we can
get a new algorithm that privately
simulates the verifier edge here we kind
of achieve a similar utility privacy
trade-off as the LT algorithm namely
when the hod
outputs accept or reject with
probability close to one our simulation
is also to Output that verdict and our
simulation and linkers are privacy loss
when the outcome is rejected
our algorithm has additional advantage
of being always Purity as long as we
started with geography based algorithms
and our algorithm has a simpler
description and Analysis
and in the third set of our results
which is the most technically most
interesting part of our contribution we
propose a method to boost the confidence
of private testing
and our method is especially advantages
when there are a large number of
learning tasks and as application we are
able to improve the dependence on the
confidence parameter in private
multiplicative weights updates and
adaptive data analysis
uh so in these two applications the
sparse Vector the standard sparse Vector
plays a cable is a it is a key component
in these two applications and their
underlying algorithms and since we are
using private testing to generalize and
ultimately improving the smart micro
technique it is those price that we are
able to improve these two algorithms
uh okay that's now let me highlight one
technique called innovation of our paper
which is a method for boosting
confidence for private testing and we
will use the sparse Vector technique for
illustration in this talk
okay this is our main results three
so in one sentence our contribution is
2.8 new method to boost confidence by
repetition and here are in more detail
let's start by reviewing the standard
response Vector technique here given a
query fi under the threshold T the
sparse Vector technique wants to verify
if FY of the data set is less than the
threshold of the key to do that the
standard SVT adds a noise to the FI
value so consider fi of D plus LaPlace
noise with magnitude roughly one or
Epsilon so if I plus noise is less than
a threshold uh then what can we say
about fiod well at least we can say that
with probability one minus Delta f i of
D is upper bounded by T plus one minus
Epsilon Times log 1 over Delta similarly
if I plus noise is greater than the
threshold then at least we can say that
with the probability one minus Delta we
are confident that FY is lower bounded
by T minus as one were Epsilon Times log
one over Delta
and here this one or Epsilon Times log
on our Delta term is considered the
additive error of the response Vector
technique and you can notice that this
term scales linearly with log 1 over
Delta and here we ask the question can
we do better
it turns out we can in a particular
parameter regime
so let me set our algorithm given the
query fi and the T as considered run the
test F5 plus noise
against key independently for log 1 R
Delta many runs
so let's consider the outcome of these
tests tests if all the test returns less
than then we are at least one minus
Delta confidence that fyot is less than
T this is called just because if fi is
greater than T then we fail each test
with probability at least one half and
it's very unlikely that we fill none of
these tests so uh in this case so if all
the test returns less than uh we kind of
get the conclusion that f i over D is
less than the threshold of the T without
apparently paying any privacy loss
because you know in the standard SVT you
incur a privacy loss only if the outcome
is greater than
however uh what if one of the tests
returns greater than uh in that case we
are not so confident that FY over D is
greater than T because uh because
especially when Delta is extremely small
then log 1 of Delta is large we repeat
these tests for many when we repeat the
test for many times uh we are
getting more likely to see the result at
F5 plus noise is greater than t
uh still we might hope that fi of D is
at least a lower bounded by T minus uh
quantity that's what we would like to
verify in The Next Step so if we happen
to enter the second case then we
consider comparing F5 with T minus Delta
for some parameter Delta we are going to
set later
so to verify this inequality we consider
comparing F5 plus noise versus T minus
Delta for another logo our Delta runs
and here the similar reasoning goes so
if all the tests returns greater than we
are at least one minus Delta confidence
that f i is at least P minus Delta and
here similarly we get the verdict
without paying privacy loss however if
one of the tests returns less than uh we
are not very confident that FY is less
than T minus Delta but still we switch
back we can switch back to test if fi is
at is upper bounded by T
and in general our algorithm alternate
between testing F5 is less than T and fi
is greater than T minus Delta we
alternate testing these two clamps and
here we pass one over there
uh
and
so
to make this work there are many
technical details we need to fill in but
here are two most significant
significant issues that I would like to
highlight and I hope to by explaining
these two issues I hope to convince you
that our approach is a plausible one
so the first issue is how to control the
privacy laws in our ALG result so we
recall that in the smart sector
technique each time you get a about
threshold result you need to pay the
Privacy loss and yeah in our context
each time we switch to run another test
we need to pay the primates loss and in
our algorithm recall that we are
alternating between F5 less than
something and F5 greater than some C uh
we are alternating between these two
tests back and forth and it's uh it
might happen that we are just we are we
are just waste our privacy budget by
alternate these two tests without
getting a useful conclusion
so how to avoid these bad cases well it
turns out by stating this parameter
Delta to be reasonably large we can show
that this event happens rarely so in in
particular so if we are interested in
answering a total number of M queries
and spices to set Delta to be one or
Epsilon Times log M plus log log of our
Delta and in that case we can show that
uh we are indeed using the vast majority
of our promise body to answer meaningful
queries we are not wasting our privacy
value to doing this back and force theme
and here also intuitively Delta is the
additive error of our algorithm namely
by using our algorithm we are able to
distinguish between the case that fi is
less than T minus Delta from the case
that fi is greater than T but if fi lies
in between T minus Delta and the T our
algorithm can output uh both uh I mean
both outcomes and
in that case we think both outcomes as
being valid
uh the second issue is that in the
standard SVT one also needs to add noise
to the threshold key and so one can
think that if uh if the noise added to
the thresholder is already large enough
then it does not make much sense to do
this by kind of force test to see so to
resolve this issue we observe that there
is a version of a sparse Vector that
only adds noise to the threshold ones
and adding noise to the threshold wires
is not a uh it's not impressive the more
impressive thing is that by adding noise
to the threshold only once you can add a
much smaller noise to achieve privacy
and it is exactly the much smaller noise
that allows us to improve on the
application is that we'll mention soon
so let's do issues I would like to
highlight and this technique I mean this
sketch skips many details in our
implementation of this idea and if you
are interested I encourage you to see
our paper for more details
uh let me mention the application to
private multiplicative white update and
adaptive data analysis so for private
multiplicity rate update let's set up is
that uh so first of all this is a
private implementation over the
multiplicative white update algorithm uh
the setup is that we are given examples
from a finite universe and then we can
answer them in your queries with these
samples within Alpha Arrow Alpha where
the alpha grows only logarithmically
with the number of queries and
uh this algorithm achieves different
privacy guarantee and a reasonably high
confidence
and when applying this private
multiplication updates to Adaptive data
analysis we can answer M adaptively
choosing linear queries within error
Alpha and confidence one minus beta and
the sample complexity grows
logarithmically with the number of
queries
using our new sparse Vector Technique we
are able to further improve the error
and the sample.com x80 in particular the
new bound looks like the following
uh so basically everything else remains
unchanged but we are able to decouple
the dependence on local data from that
on other factors and we kind of achieved
it optimal dependence on Logo our data
and this is the main message of our
Improvement
let me wrap up so in this work we
following to build four prior works we
proposed yet a new method for conducting
Private Selection and testing our method
offers similar or sometimes better
privacy utility trade-off as prior works
but our analysis is significantly
simpler and in something is our paper
generalized sparse vector and
explanation mechanism not only the
application and algorithm but also the
proof
uh we for the extent of these Frameworks
in two directions uh in One Direction We
showcase how to use Private Selection to
boost the confidence Bound for popular
or private data analysis tasks and in
the second direction we show that how to
boost confidence for the private testing
framework in the Ally setting and as a
result we are able to improve the sample
complexity dependence on the confidence
parameter in private multiplicative
weight updates and adaptive data
analysis that that's all I want to say
today thank you for your attention